يكون معنا الان اللواء فايز الدويري
للتعليق على هذا التطور اللافت في ضوء هذه
المعطيات البسيطه المتوفره
فايز الدويري طائرتان مسيرتان تهاجمان اذا
الكرملين
لا مزيد من المعلومات سوى ان
القوات الروسيه عطلت هتان الطائرتان ماذا
تقرا على المستوى العسكري والاستراتيجي في
هذا الاستهداف للكرملين ولاول مره
تحول دراماتيكي تحول غير متوقع وحتى من
اتخذ القرار بتنفيذ هذا العمل
اعتقد ان قراءاته لم تكن رايي الشخصي لم
تكن موفقه عندما تم استهداف جسر كيرش
تحدثنا بنفس اليوم وقلنا هذا يعتبر رمز
سيادي وسيكون الرد
مؤلم وكان باليوم التالي الرد المؤلم وبدا
تحول المقاربه الروسي الى استهداف مراكز
الطاقه
ومر الشتاء القاسي على الشعب الاوكراني
وكانت النقطه التحول في الاستهداف هي
مهاجمه جسر كرش الان استهداف الكريم كان
هناك حديث قبل اسابيع عن محاوله اغتيال
واعتبرت تلك المعلومات انها غير دقيقه او
انها مس خره لخدمته هدف ما الان نتحدث عن
تطور دراماتيكي الان خروج قطار عن سكه
بسبب عمل تقريبي
طائرتين بغض النظر على الصوره تشير امامنا
ان هناك اصابه في قطب احد في قبه الكرملين
اللواء فايز يعني طائره
هذا يعني لا استطيع ان احدد لانه انظر الى
الصوره الصوره تعطينا ان هناك اصطدام
وانفجار الجانب الروسيه
اذا كان هذا الانفجار هو كما قال الروس هو
في ضربه تلقتها الطائره على بعد مسافه ما
من القبه ام انها اصابه للقبه ولكن انت
ادرى فايز ولكن يبدو الارجح انها الاصابه
للطائره وليس القبه
يعني اذا كانت اصابه للطائره من خلال
الصوره هي اصيبت على ارتفاع قريب جدا من
القبه يعني لانه لاحظ هناك جسم متحرك
باتجاه القبه ومن ثم يحدث الانفجار لم ارى
صاروخا مقابلا يعني هنا انا لا احاول ان
ارجع شيء على شيء لانه الصوره لا تعطي
انطباعا او فكره كامله لكن هناك جسم متحرك
باتجاه القبه لم نشاهد جسما يلتقي به ممكن
اتصل
فقط اشير الى الصور التي نشاهدها يعني على
نصف الشاشه نشاهد صور الكرملين وهذه
الطائره التي كنت تتحدث عنها ولكن في
النصف الاخر هذه صور قبل قليل للرئيس
فلاديمير بوتين وهو يجتمع بعدد من اركان
حكومته وطبعا الكرملين اشار الى انه يعمل
اليوم من مقر اقامته
يعني بالقرب من موسكو ولم يكن
في الكرم لان الساعه وقوع هذه
الحادثه
من يجري الان لواء فايزه الدويري يفتح
التساؤل حول ما بعد هذا الهجوم هل يمكن
توقع رد الفعل الروسي نظرا لاتهام
اوكرانيا بتنفيذ هذا الهجوم
يعني روسيا اشارت سيكون هناك الرد في
الزمان والمكان المناسبين الذي يتم
اختياره من قبل القياده السياسيه
ومن قبل القياده العسكريه واخذ الاخضر من
القياده السياسيه الان اذا الان اعتمدت
الروايه الروسيه على ان الهجوم هو نفذ من
قبل اوكرانيا او من قبل جهاز الاستخبارات
الاوكراني اعتقد ان الرد سيكون بالمثل
مشابه اي بمعنى اخر ستكون القياده
السياسيه والقيادات العليا في الدائره
العسكريه والامنيه ضمن الاهداف المشروعه
من وجهه النظر الروسيه وروسيا تمتلك
المنظومات صواريخ
فائقه الدقه وعاليه السرعه فرض صوتيه
وبالتالي دعيني اقول ان الحرب قبل بدء
هجوم الربيع الذي الكل كان يتوقعه اخذت
منحنى تصعيدي خطير جدا يعني لا يمكن
التنبؤ
بخواتم الامور في هذا الاتجاه هل سيكون
الرد الروسي
من نفس العمل الذي تم اذا كانت اوكرانيا
وراءه هل سيتم باستهداف الرئيس الذي يتم
اهداف استهداف الدائره المقربه وكبار
القيادات الامنيه الامنيه والعسكريه اعتقد
ان هذه اهداف من وجهه نظر روسيا ستكون
اهدافا مشروعه
فايز الدويري يعني مكان مثل الكرملين
وبهيبه الكرملين يخضع لتعزات امنيه مراقبه
استخبارات مخابرات كيف لم يرصد
طائرتان او طائرتين مسيرتين باتجاه
يعني اثير العديد من التساؤلات حول
فعاليات المنظومات الدفاع الجوي الروسي قد
يكون التساؤلات مشروعه في بعض الاماكن
ولكنها غير مشروعه وغير مقبوله ولكن هناك
اشاره
ميناء
الرئيسي الرئيسي في شبه جزيره القرن ومقر
القياده البحريه الروسيه في البحر الاسود
بالامس كان هناك طائره هاجمت كان يمكن
الهجوم لم اعد استطيع تتبع الاعداد لكن
ليس ليس اقل من الهجوم الثالث عشر او
الرابع عشر يستهدف نفس الهدف وتستطيع
طائرات الاختراق علما ان روسيا والمعلومات
التي لدينا من خلال متابعاتنا والمتابعه
الابحاث التي تنشر ان روسيا تتفوق على
الغرب في نظام الدفاع الجوي تحديدا متخلفه
بالطائرات ولكنها مت فوقه يعني منظومه اس
400 تعتبر يد منظومه الاكثر تطورا في
العالم اكثر من الباتريوت باك 3 واكثر من
منظومه ساد كيف ما تفسير هل هي عدم التصدي
لهذه الطائرات قبل اقترابها في الاساس
الان
يجب ان نحدد مكان الخطا
اولا هذه لم تطلق صواريخ باتجاه هذه
الطائرات عندما كانت متجهه باتجاه الكرمل
اذا هل لم يتم كشف هناك خطا في دائره
العمل الثلاثيه لمنظومه الدفاع الجوي
نتحدث عن منظومه راداريه نتحدث منظومه
قياده وسيطره منظومه راداريه منظومه
تنفيذيه هذه المنظومات الثلاث عملها
متكامل يجب لاكتشاف الاهداف يعني منظومه
القياده والسيطره تاخذ الاستقباري الرؤيه
البعد الراداري الان تاتي وحده القياده
والسيطره الان نقل المعلومه من معلومه
استخباريه الى وحده القياده والسيطره الى
الوحده التنفيذيه هذا هذا المثلث رؤوس
المثلث متصله ام هناك ثغره ما حدثت سواء
في تمرير المعلومه في اكتشاف الطائرات في
عمليه الاطلاق اذا واحد من ثلاثه حدث خطا
الكشف عدم توصيل المعلومه عدم الاطلاق لا
غير ذلك من خلال خبرتي لا استطيع ان احدد
مسارا رابعا او سببا رابعا لعدم اسقاط
ناتي الان نقطه في جمله واحده جمله واحده
هو رمز السياده السوفيتيه والروسيه
وبالتالي ان يتم اقتحامه يعيدني الى اكثر
من خمسين سنه ماضيه عندما هبطت الطائره في
الساحه الحمراء
طيار مغامر هاوي نزل بطائرته في الساحه
الحمراء هذا في القرن الماضي اذا هناك خلل
ما لا استطيع ان احدده ولكن اضعه واحد من
ثلاث فشلت من المنظومه الراداريه فشل في
نقل المعلومه واصالها فشل في عمليه
التنفيذ والاطلاق عندما نقول او عندما
يقول الروس يعني انه تم تعطيل هذا هو
اللفظ الذي استخدم تعطيل طائرتين
المسيرتين
هل التعطيل هو بالضروره عن طريق استهداف
الطائره بصاروخ ام هناك وسائل اخرى في
منظومه الدفاع الجوي يمكنها ان تعطر
الطائرات المسيره
يا سيدي الان دعنا نقول تعطيل كما قالوا
او تحييد او ابطال الان
حسب
نظريه الدفاع الجوي القائمه في روسيا من
موسكو حتى الحدود الغربيه هي تحمل اللون
الاصفر وهذا اللون الاصفر يعني ان هناك
درجه استعداد عاليه جدا لوحدات الدفاع
الجوي من ضمن وسائل الدفاع الجوي عمليه
الجامد او عمليه التشويش اي التشويش على
ايه
طائره حربيه سواء كانت مجنحه او عموديه او
طائره مسيره وبالتالي الروس كانوا يقولوا
لدينا القدره على التشويش وعلى ابطال
فاعليه منظومه العمل الالكتروني في في هذه
الطائره منظومه العمل هذه
الان عندما نقول تم تعطيلها الاصل في
التعطيل ان يكون تدمير او عمليه ابطال
فاعليته واسقاطها في مكان اخر لكن الذي
لاحظناه ان هناك عمليه التفجير هي ضمن
اطار محيط الكرمله
تحدثت عن اسباب كثيره لواء فايز الدويري
منها فشل منظومه الرادار عدم الابلاغ في
وقت مبكر هل كان بالامكان تفادي حدوث او
وصول الطائرتين الى
مبنى في حال تم اتباع الخطوات اللازمه في
تقديرك
يعني الان دعينا اقول كلمه الامان المطلق
الامان المطلق او ناخذ
درجه مئه بالمئه هذه غير موجوده في كل نظم
الدفاع الجوي ولكن عندما وبالتالي من هذا
المنطلق التعامل مع اي هدف جوي يكون تعامل
مزدوج يعني الطائره يتم اطلاق صاروخين
علما ان كفاءه الصاروخ في بعض الحالات 90%
فانا هنا اطلق صاروخين بحيث تصبح دقه
الاصابه او ضمان النتيجه 180% نظريا نظريا
وليس فعليا لكن لماذا لان درجه العشره
بالمئه هي هي في كل صاروخ وبالتالي لا
استطيع ان اجمع رياضيا سيبقى لدي من خلال
نظريه الاحتمالات ان العشره بالميه قد
اكلها مقابل التسعين بالمئه لهذا السبب
يتم وضع اكثر من نظام دفاع جوي البيت
الابيض محمي باكثر من البنتا وانا دخلت
البنتاجون اكثر من مره محمي باكثر من نظام
صاروخي كان محميا بالهوك
وبالتالي هناك اكثر من منظومه رادار ليس
من النوع الواحد انما اكثر من منظومه وهذا
الامر يجب ان يكون موجود حول الكرملين
ويجب ان تكون صواريخ اس 400 من ضمن
الصواريخ
الموجوده ضمن اطار الكريم هي موجوده في
قاعده تحميم هل قاعده تحميميهم اكثر اهميه
من الكرملين